so here's a question I get a lot what
can I do with a physics degree but as
someone who's just done a physics degree
and is now a PhD student in physics I
thought I'd give my take on an answer to
this question but I'm going to base it
on personal stories from my friends and
classmates my thoughts on this topic of
employability and physics are based on
largely on anecdotes and of course
employability is something that's going
to differ widely depending on which
country you're in or what kind of person
you are so I'll post some links in the
description to some more stats or
research-based information on this topic
and just tell you what I think the truth
is that if you're a motivated student
then you can do almost anything with a
physics degree this is because whilst
you're learning physics that's not the
only thing you're doing you're not just
to memorizing facts about the atoms or
space-time you're also learning how to
code simulations or to process large
amounts of data you're learning to
critically evaluate research and to
communicate ideas this is what makes a
physics graduate employable to a broad
range of careers because any industry
that's needing to understand trends and
data and to use their for their
advantage they're going to find your
skills useful and that's pretty much
every industry nowadays whilst I chose
to go on and do PhD in physics many of
my friends did not and they went
straight out and got jobs whether that
was at the government in roles such as
defense policy modeling or nuclear
science others went down the road of
becoming a high school teacher or they
went into medical physics working in a
hospital or into science communication
there as a journalist or a technical
writer actually most people that I know
who got graduate jobs are working as
software developers of some kind whether
that's for a start-up for a medical
devices company or at Google since
physics is so closely linked to
engineering I also know a few people who
have gone on into engineering fields
whether that rocketry or material
science how well-placed you ask for
these sorts of jobs really depends on
what kind of internships or research
projects you choose to do during your
degree so for example if you want to end
up in some sort of software job try to
pick to work on projects that involve a
lot of coding and try to participate in
related competitions and stuff in your
own time as well I did a couple of
research internships both at a
university and an observatory and those
were really good for me because I wanted
to go into post-grad and do research but
doing things that you know are going to
help you get to where you want to go
going to be what sets you apart from
other people a fair number of physics
students do stay on and do post-grad and
I think that's just because the kind of
curious people that want to study
physics in the first place are also kind
of the people that want to do their own
research you could go down this path and
endeavor to become a postdoc or a
lecture or a professor and stay in the
academic circles or at anytime you can
go out and get an industry job with us
physics degree you can even do post-grad
studies in another discipline popular
choices would be maths or computer
science another kind of science or even
finance this
in fact a lot of the PhD students I'm
working with now have ambitions to
eventually create startup businesses
from some of their research or from the
skills they're learning in physics
pretty much if you're creative and are
not afraid of applying your skills to an
unfamiliar area you can do whatever you
want with a physics degree physics has a
reputation for being hard and what
you're doing by completing a physics
degree is showing any potential employer
that you're good at cackling new
problems and you are motivated by
learning new things so good luck